the United States has fallen to 48th in
the world in press freedom right below
Botswana and Chile and Romania and when
we talk about American exceptionalism
there are areas where the u.s.
legitimately leads the world but there
are also areas where many Americans
think we are at the top and were
actually not so like an example would be
infant mortality among the developed
world the United States is near the
worst when it comes to infant mortality
education if you look at math and
science test scores for kids we're way
behind a lot of the world in the United
States the so-called business climate
which many think is so great in the
United States turns out there are lots
and lots of countries where the
environment is better for
entrepreneurship and for starting
businesses than in the United States
when it comes to freedom of speech and
specifically freedom of the press we
might think that we're near the top but
we're actually not even though you might
think journalists are able to just do
their thing everyone's free to report on
those in power it's all delightful in
the United States it's not and the new
Press Freedom Index from Reporters
Without Borders has the u.s. down even
further from 45th to 48th in the world
right below Botswana Chile and Romania
and now solidly in a section of
countries called problematic from a
freedom of the press standpoint Norway
is again at the top
Sweden is near the top the Netherlands
and the reason why the United States
continues to slide partially has to do
with Donald Trump's continued attacks on
the press this is actually a global
trend that we're seeing in total
journalistic independence has been sort
of pushed down over the last year safety
for journalists globally is down but in
terms of the United States
you've got Donald Trump's anti media
rhetoric more and more journalists
needing security protection Trump
talking about requiring journalism
licenses Trump talking about making it
easier to sue media outlets Trump
talking about shutting media outlets
down Trump talking about how it would be
nice to have state media and this is
fomenting a sort of climate of disbelief
towards media outlets and it's part of
this package that Donald Trump embodies
of authoritarian strongman behavior
which around the world is increasing
violence against journalists as we've
seen with a number of stories over the
last several weeks when Trump says what
you're hearing and what you're seeing
you shouldn't believe it you should
believe me instead that is
extraordinarily anti freedom of the
press and trust of the press and then
there's another aspect to this that's
really important but it's not always
discussed the right-wing nationalists
who do the entire if you question the
commander in chief if you question our
health care system if you question our
military engagements you're not
patriotic and you're anti-american that
same ideology foments the anti media
sentiment when media critically reports
on what the government is doing which
they should right I mean that's you've
got to hold the accountable you've got
to hold the powerful accountable the
nationalist sentiment that brands
individuals as unpatriotic for
questioning the government does the same
thing to media in the same way that
there is an enclave of nationalists in
the u.s. who if you question what the
hell are we doing in Iraq for example
you're branded is unpatriotic if you are
a media outlet that questions what we're
doing in Iraq to use the same example
you were equally branded as unpatriotic
and it is creating and catalyzing and
growing this anti media environment in a
way that is literally physically
dangerous for journalists in the United
States and elsewhere and there's a
growing portion of the American
population that actually agrees with
Donald Trump that the media is the enemy
of the people that you can't believe
what you're seeing and hearing with your
own eyes and this is a massive problem
and the more people believe this the
worse it's going to get for journalists
and for press freedom if you believe in
American exceptionalism
you shouldn't be happy with being ranked
48th in press freedom when it's codified
in the Constitution of the United States
in the bill of rights to the
Constitution of the United States if you
really want to talk about American
exceptionalism we should be disgusted
that were 48th in terms of press freedom
I want to hear from you about this I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show let me
know what you think today's episode is
sponsored in part by the BRD Bitcoin
wallet whether you have experience with
Bitcoin and crypto currencies or you've
been wanting to give it a try for the
first time BRD offers the most elegant
easy to use Bitcoin wallet out there
it's an app on Android and iOS lets you
trade crypto currencies store all of
your Bitcoin and crypto on the app
totally free send and receive Bitcoin
with the app use a credit card to
purchase cryptocurrency
and it's 100% private and secure
virtually impossible for someone to hack
your account BRD themselves won't even
know your information there are no
logins no passwords you just use your
key to access your Bitcoin and you're
the only one who has access to it it was
the first-ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS
App Store they've been around since 2014
they have more than two million users
BRD is one of the oldest most
established and most trusted Bitcoin
wallets in the industry we recently
interviewed Aaron from the BRD team and
it was a great conversation you should
search our channel for it and check it
out all BRD wants to do is to make
Bitcoin more accessible and simpler to
use for those who want to use it and
that's what they've accomplished with
their super powerful easy to use app
download it it's perfect for anyone
who's just getting started with Bitcoin
just as good if you already know what
you're doing I've put a link underneath
this video